we don't teach difficult conversations
we don't uh teach conflict resolution we
don't teach uh de-escalation uh and we
don't teach how to give and receive
feedback we don't teach how to treat
ideas we don't even teach people how to
have a meeting
like we don't teach any of these things
and so we're just leaving it up to
chance to hope that somebody knows what
they're doing which we would never let
somebody on the front line do we give
them tons of training on how to do their
jobs so part of it is is is the skill
set that we that we can train um the
other thing is um a lot of leaders i
think are afraid of doing things for
fear of saying the wrong thing and again
this this really lends itself to the
training we need to give our leaders and
especially i think this was really
exaggerated after the murder of george
floyd um
where so many leaders did nothing
um they're not bad people
uh they were just so afraid of saying
the wrong thing or inflaming a situation
or triggering someone that they chose to
to just do nothing um and so one of the
things we need to do is teach people how
to lean into tension um uh and and to
learn how to de-escalate one's own anger
or or one's own trigger and again you
brought it up before which is and
replace it with curiosity tell me more
what else i'm struggling to understand
let me tell you the story that's going
through my head i think is a really big
one that i've learned which is because
i'm reacting based on my own narrative
right and so they're reacting to my
words or my reaction and so one of the
things that's really helped me is to
share what's going on in my head so that
people have the context of where my
reaction's coming from let me let me
tell you what my history is and what my
background is i'm not saying this is
right or wrong i'm just telling you my
story and i'll say i had this happen in
the past where x y and z and so i'm
nervous at your suggestion because in
the past this has happened can you help
me resolve this or do you understand
where i'm coming from
and i think the more we can share what's
going on in the process rather than
simply you know responding with our
answers or our reactions helps the other
person see the way we're trying to see
it and it also encourages us to see the
way they're trying to see it so i think
the more we share it's that
vulnerability word again right let me
tell you my history let me tell you my
baggage let me tell you my background
let me tell you my experiences let me
tell you where my opinion is coming from
um
the worst thing the one that drives me
up the wall the one that triggers me is
this is how we've always done it
well why do we do it that way because
this is how we've always done it and my
rule is if you cannot tell me
why we're doing it this way that means
it's it's on the chopping block that
doesn't mean it has to change but but i
wanna i want real explanations of why we
do something this way if somebody can't
tell me then then then it's open to
being changed